[Música]
a
es claro que la época navideña este año
alemania va a ser distinta va a ser
extraña distinta porque la mayoría de
los mercadillos de navidad esa tradición
tan importante para los alemanes en esta
época del año han sido cancelados para
evitar aglomeraciones masivas distintas
porque la vida pública ha sido reducida
drásticamente en muy pocos eventos
culturales y los bares los restaurantes
y los museos continúan cerrados distinta
porque hay límites en cuanto al número
de personas que pueden hacer compras al
tiempo en los almacenes que permanecen
abiertos distinta porque una de las
grandes tradiciones de año nuevo en este
país esas celebraciones masivas en las
calles con fuegos artificiales también
han sido cancelados esto no significa
sin embargo que los alemanes no vayan a
poder celebrar la navidad el gobierno
estimó y decidió que máximo diez
personas excluyendo a los niños podrán
reunirse entre el 23 de diciembre y el
1º de enero a celebrar la navidad de esa
manera las autoridades por un lado
esperan que las restricciones ayuden a
reducirlos
casos de coronavirus y por el otro lado
igual se pueda garantizar que los
alemanes celebren la navidad en familia
[Música]
los británicos tendrán un respiro de 5
días del 23 al 27 de diciembre ya que el
gobierno autorizó reunirse entre un
máximo de 3 hogares y formar una burbuja
social para celebrar estas fiestas
navideñas
además levantará las restricciones de
viaje en el reino unido- para que las
personas puedan desplazarse y reunirse
brevemente con sus seres queridos eso sí
los abrazos y los besos a los abuelos no
están recomendados por el riesgo de
contagio las tiendas le abrirán sus
puertas después de este segundo
confinamiento nacional a partir del
próximo 3 de diciembre a tiempo para las
compras navideñas también los
restaurantes y los tradicionales pops
ingleses podrán recibir gente a partir
de la próxima semana con restricciones y
con distanciamiento social y es que el
reino unido ha sido el país más golpeado
por la pandemia en europa con más de 57
mil muertes oficiales
[Música]
uno de los mayores acontecimientos
navideños en españa' es el sorteo
extraordinario de lotería de navidad que
se celebra el 22 de diciembre y en el
que se calcula que participa la mitad de
la población con un gasto medio por
español de unos 70 euros y los españoles
compran directamente aquí en las
oficinas de loterías y apuestas del
estado pero también en el trabajo en
clubes deportivos o en bares y
restaurantes sus participaciones un
último depósito de la esperanza para
mejorar la situación económica sobre
todo en estos tiempos de crisis y para
paliar esta crisis autoridades como la
alcaldesa de barcelona ha pedido a la
población que realice las compras
navideñas también en locales de
proximidad y por lo que hace a la
vertiente más social y familiar de estas
fiestas falta que el gobierno acuerde
con las autonomías su propuesta que de
momento limita las reuniones a un máximo
de seis personas y permite que en
nochebuena y en nochevieja se retrase el
toque de queda hasta la una de la
madrugada
[Música]